have you ever wondered if each of the
Disney Princesses married the right man
we reckon we found better matches for
each of our girls keep watching to
discover which Disney character would
have two princesses fighting over him
and he's not even a prince here's our
take on which Disney characters the
Disney Princesses should have married
great she brings home a sword if you ask
me she should have brought home a nice
excuse me this family lives here Ariel
and Aladdin Ariel ended up marrying
Prince Eric in the Little Mermaid but we
think she might have even more fun with
that self-confessed streetrat Aladdin
we all know that Ariel is obsessed with
humans and the world above the sea and
that must have played a big part in her
instant attraction to Eric after all he
was the first team in man she'd ever
seen sure he's handsome in kind but his
level of adventure was taking Ariel on a
carriage ride we reckon Ariel might get
bored with Eric eventually she's so full
of enthusiasm for new experiences could
Eric keep giving her what she needs so
the question is who would be more
exciting Aladdin back to when Aladdin
was a street rat he lived life on the
edge he stole food to survive and
tricked the palace guards let's not
forget Ariel is also a rule-breaker
going against her father's wishes so
she'd be thrilled by Aladdin's
mischievous side plus area would adore
going for a ride on his magic carpet
after all you can't get any further from
the ocean than the sky Aladdin is
certainly one fun guy his sense of
adventure would also make him a great
match with Rapunzel we picked someone
else for her though so stay tuned to
find out who so if Aladdin is switching
to Ariel where does that leave jasmine
we've got just the perfect match for her
jasmine and Flynn Rider yes we know his
real name is Eugene Fitzherbert but we
think jasmine would be attracted to the
thieving mischievous version which is
why she'd still call him Flynn after all
when Jasmine climbs over the palace
walls and sneaks around the marketplace
she isn't above a little stealing
herself sure she doesn't realize the
rules which is why she takes an apple
for a little kid without paying for it
but there's definitely a rebellious
touch to Jasmine she defies her father
refuses to marry any of his suitors and
runs away from home she is no goody
two-shoes and Flynn starts out as a
total troublemaker
jasmin wouldn't fall for Flint's attempt
at charm but not because of naivety
which is why Rapunzel was immune to his
advances to begin with instead Flynn
would meet his match in Jasmine
they'd have amazing banter we can just
imagine them having a fiery passionate
relationship so if plan is with jasmine
what about Rapunzel we have come up with
a new match for her and it's keeping it
in the family
awkward Rapunzel and Kristoff why would
it be awkward for a Rapunzel to marry
Kristoff well because he was in love
with Anna and fans up theorized that
Rapunzel is cousins with Anna and Elsa
one of the pieces of evidence for this
connection is that Rapunzel and Flynn
are seen attending Elsa's coronation in
frozen so if we did switch up this pair
any future family gatherings would
definitely be uncomfortable but why do
we think Rapunzel suits Kristoff better
than Flynn Rider they have plenty in
common neither of them were raised by
their birth parents they both built
solid friendships with animals in their
childhoods spend the reindeer for
Kristoff and Pascal the chameleons for a
Rapunzel and they're both pretty quirky
with the love of the outdoors our next
new match shares cousin ties with
Rapunzel as well this theory about
family connections in the Disney verse
has actually been confirmed by frozen
director Chris buck he told MTV News
that he has a fun little story in his
head that Anna and Elsa's parents didn't
die on the boat they were actually
shipwrecked on an island they had a baby
boy before being killed by a leopard and
who was that baby boy Tarzan so he's
Rapunzel's cousin too and we think
Tarzan would make the perfect match for
another Disney Princess what have you
hate the way he picks his nose
excuse me sir he's a prince Pocahontas
and Tarzan in her first movie Pocahontas
didn't end up following John Smith back
to England she had the difficult
decision to make between her love and
her land bow we think she would be
better suited to someone else anyway and
that someone else is Tarzan why so well
firstly they have lots in common they
both fall for someone who came from
England and who led a life very
different from theirs they both had to
choose between going to England with
that person or staying with their family
and they both chose to stay given that
he was raised
by Gorillaz Tarzan is very interesting
Pocahontas was attracted to John because
she wanted something different and
Tarzan is even more different so it
makes sense that Pocahontas would be
into him he's picked up so many skills
in the jungle and enjoys living in a
natural environment Tarzan has these
qualities in common with Pocahontas so
he's a perfect blend of exciting yet on
the same wavelength
did you know Pocahontas is one of the
only two Disney Princesses to have two
love interests the other is Anna and we
reckon if Pocahontas is with Tarzan then
John Smith is free for a different
princess to marry Mulan and John Smith
Mulan is arguably the toughest out of
all the Disney Princesses she's a
fighter literally in the Chinese army so
she'd need a man with that same spirit
sure she found that in Shang but we
reckon her life would be more
adventurous with John Smith they'd enjoy
learning about each other's cultures and
they could spar together too you know
they could even start up their own
regiment together now that would be
formidable we also think Milan would be
well matched with Pocahontas other love
interest
kocoum he's strong and courageous which
is just what Milan respects but he's
also very serious which isn't exactly
her type
besides Coppola doesn't make it to the
end of the movie so we'll need to stick
with John then so what about Mulan's has
been Ching we've got someone else lined
up for him Tiana and Shang we reckon
Tiana and Milan would be besties as they
have so much in common like their work
ethic and their respect for their
fathers so it makes sense that they
would have a similar taste in men which
is why we reckon Shang would float
Tiana's boat he has great respect for
his father - which would impress Tiana
and he's a hard worker
you can't say the same for Prince Naveen
in fact he's quite the opposite
Chang has pretty sexist views until
Mulan helps him see the light we reckon
Tiana would also help Shang realize a
woman's worth he'd have great respect
for her dedication to her dream of
opening a restaurant and we're sure he'd
love her home cooking we can just
imagine these two with adorable little
kids running around at home so where
does that leave Tiana's other half
Prince Naveen
we've got just the princess for him
Cinderella and Prince Naveen
can't help but feel the three Disney
Princesses that started the whole
franchise got a bit of a raw deal with
their princess sure they were handsome
and everything but they had hardly any
character development Cinderella's
Prince Charming didn't do much other
than dance at the ball and look for the
foot that fit the glass slipper sure
Cinderella was thrilled to get hitched
to the prince but we'd like to think
that she did want more out of life in
the end spending the rest of her days
cleaning and singing wouldn't be
thrilling now would it
however if she were to end up with
someone like Prince Naveen she'd have a
much more interesting ride he's got
swagger and cheekiness and these two
actually have quite a lot in common they
both love music and that's a big point
in their favor Naveen could introduce
Cinderella to jazz music she could start
rocking out to a trumpet now that we
love to see Cinderella could help Naveen
become more self-sufficient she could
teach him how to cook and clean although
they come from very different places
they would understand each other's
family situations Naveen was cut off
from his family's money Cinderella was
cut off from her family's riches yes it
was for very different reasons but that
shared experience of being excluded
would surely bond them if you thought
Cinderella and Naveen were a weird mix
just wait until you hear our next
bizarre pairing Anna and Peter Pan yes
you heard right
we think Anna and Peter Pan could make a
good match hear us out on this one first
off we need to say that we're thinking
about Peter Pan being a bit older 18
years old to be precise the same age as
on him but still with his youthful
spirit he's the boy who never grew up
and on a totally has that young
wide-eyed enthusiasm to she wants to
shove chocolate in her face after all
anna has this superpower of love and
that's just what Peter needs Anna is a
go-getter too despite her naivety she's
willing to try new things Peter is
daring and loves adventure together they
could have a magical time we're not sure
Tinkerbell would be too happy though
Belle and Prince Eric falen Ariel would
be besties because Ariel's voice actress
Jodi Benson says so that's because she's
BFFs in real life with the woman who
voices Belle page O'Hara and she reckons
the two princesses have lots in common
plus they share the same live action
model Sherri stoner so we reckon their
taste in men could also be similar
they'll had a pretty tough ride with the
Beast before he transformed into Prince
Adam but she'd be better suited for
Ariel's husband Prince Eric we think she
could the beast was pretty angsty to say
the least he had an explosive temper
when Belle first met him Eric on the
other hand seems to have his life
together
he's pretty chill and has an easygoing
laid-back charm about him that's just
what Belle could do with after her
tumultuous experience being held captive
in the beasts castle she did dream up
there being more than her provincial
life and we're not totally convinced
Erika's worldly enough for her but he
did go on voyages across the sea so he
could take Belle on ocean adventures to
unexplored lands and they could immerse
themselves in a whole new world together
you know it definitely would be a whole
new world watching old-fashioned Golden
Age princesses with a modern-day man and
that's exactly what we've done with our
last entry Snow White or aurora with
Roger Radcliffe Snow White in Aurora
have lots in common they both love
animals and they both love to sing you
know who else loves to sing and who else
loves animals specifically dogs that is
Roger from 101 Dalmatians that's who
he's a songwriter and a pet owner and
we'd reckon he'd be a much more
interesting match for either one of
these Golden Age princesses
they each ended up with a prince that
didn't have much character Deb would
they have gotten bored there's no chance
of that with Roger and all those dogs
around we don't reckon either Aurora or
Snow White could deal with a man who
didn't have old-fashioned manners and
Roger actually does for all his quirks
when he first meets Anita and they end
up falling in the pond
he's as chivalrous as they come we could
actually see Cinderella with Roger too
given her love of singing but we think
it's enough to have two princesses vying
for him if Aurora gave up on Roger we
could see her being happy with Prince
Eric he has that balance of adventure
and reliability and if Snow White didn't
end up with Roger we could totally see
her with Prince Adam aka the bees so
there you have it our take on the
characters the Disney Princesses should
have married did we get it right which
alternate matches do you have for your
favorite Disney Prince
let us know in the comments section
below thanks for watching make sure to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one we'll see you next time
[Music]